this just happened in the Nebraska State
House Troopers had to arrest six people
in the Nebraska state capitol
for a number of different eventses one
of which was caught on security camera
we had the footage and it's one of these
pro-trans people punching a cop in the
face
and then the cops take down the
pro-trans dude and all the rest of these
miscreant looking people doesn't arrest
all of them probably they should but
arrests the ones who were becoming
particularly violent what do we make of
this do we conclude oh wow look at the
hypocrisy do we conclude oh wow if the
shoe were on the other foot no no we all
know that already what do we conclude we
conclude that the next time the
Democrats try to push their January 6th
narrative don't buy it it was always
nonsense